in our series the new normal we look at
how the pandemic is dramatically
changing our everyday lives
much like the airlines america's
passenger railroad
amtrak is facing the worst economic
disaster
in its history an unprecedented drop in
demand is forcing service cuts
and furloughs chris van cleave spoke to
amtrak's new ceo
and took a ride to see what's changed
all aboard doesn't amount to much these
days the pandemic has flattened amtrak
ridership
on our quick half hour trip from
washington to baltimore
joshua bailey was one of the handful on
board it hasn't been packed at all
so that's a good thing amtrak is capping
ridership at 50 percent for distancing
and requiring masks for all on board
plexiglas barriers have been added in
the cafe car and in the stations
the first thing you're going to notice
there aren't that many people on board
this is a five-car train two of them are
almost completely empty in fact amtrak
says ridership
is down in the range of 85 percent
the biggest change you probably won't
see is amtrak's new cleaning protocol
the trains are disinfected at the end of
trips they have air filters that
circulate cabin air
40 to 50 times an hour completely
replacing the air in a car
every four to five minutes touch
surfaces are wiped down before departure
and during the trip we have now focused
more so on making sure
handles seats tables bathrooms contact
points
are all cleaned thoroughly like the
trains the stations are quiet largely
empty
many of the businesses at washington's
union station are closed and seating
areas have been removed to encourage
distance this was supposed to be the
year amtrak
broke even for the first time in its 49
year history
but by the time new ceo bill flynn
officially started in april
ridership was in free fall down 97
percent
did you have a moment where you were
like what did i get myself into no i
never had that
what did i get myself into a moment i
mean the situation that
where it's happening here at amtrak it's
happening across our country
how concerned are you that some of your
customers don't come back
i think that's a question everyone in
transportation is asking themselves
today
amtrak has already reduced service and
will cut most long-haul trains from
daily to a few trips per week in october
that's causing pushback from 16 senators
who sign letters criticizing the move
montana steve daines writing it's
irrevocably hurting hundreds of
communities in small towns already
devastated by the covet 19 pandemic
i want to be clear we're fully committed
to our long distance service
amtrak now expects next year's ridership
to be cut
in half forcing the furlough of 20
percent of its workforce by october
it's part of an effort to slash costs by
500 million dollars
while asking the federal government
which subsidizes the railroad
for more than 3.5 billion to weather the
pandemic next year
very difficult decision the ultimate
decision is to size
the company as best we can we're
operating at about sixty percent
of our normal capacity against about
fifteen percent level of riderships
our intention is to restore services we
certainly want to bring
people back
flynn expects many of these new cleaning
protocols to be part of
a lasting new normal amtrak has required
masks
since may they say passenger compliance
has been pretty good but
if somebody refuses to wear a mask they
can be denied boarding
if they're not wearing it on the train
they can be told to get off at the next
stop
anthony chris van cleave reporting
taking a ride on amtrak for us thanks
chris
you also have some changes for airline
mass policies chris what is the latest
on that
sure this week we have seen four major
u.s carriers tighten their mass policies
delta on monday
said if you don't want to wear a mask
you have to speak to a medical
professional
at the airport to receive an exemption
otherwise you've got to wear it united
american and southwest yesterday
said anybody above the age of two has to
wear a mask united american
says you need to wear the mask at the
airports as well as on the flight
if you don't comply you can be banned
from flying that airline
throughout the remainder of the pandemic
anthony yeah rules on mass tightening
all over chris thank you very much